so
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to a special
divisional round edition of the squad
ride live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings if you were with
us last week squad ride cash patrick
mahomes threw for the most passing yards
so shout out to greg shout out to the
squad we are riding high right now and
we hope to do it again and we hope to do
it with your help and as always greg's
got a lot to give away he's got the
hoodies but the playoffs hit a little
different so greg let's welcome you in
and tell them what you got this weekend
connor the question of the day is what
aren't we giving the people today that's
the question we've got custom odds
boosts from our friends over at
draftkings over a thousand
dk dollars were given away today we got
hoodies of course
jerseys
and a pair
of airpods
maxes bro a pair of airpods max's connor
do you
have a pair of airpod maxes
i do not greg we're giving away all the
good stuff on the show giving it away
not keeping it that's the key uh and i
hear the airpod maxes are over the ear
which would save me from the problem of
them falling out onto the subway tracks
and never seeing them again so we
switched it up last week we asked for
who is throwing for the most passing
yards of course we're going back to our
roots on divisional weekend right if you
watch the show all year you know the
deal we want to know who are the locks
to get in the end zone we ask you on
social we ask you in the app from
scoring it's the playoffs baby who's
getting in the end zone here's some of
the most popular picks that you sent us
the featured anytime touchdown odds the
king is back derek henry at the top of
the board minus 190 cooper cup and
devonte adams even at -135 no surprise
there with how dominant those two have
been we know what gronk does in the
playoffs we know how much brady loves
mike evans cam akers a miraculous return
from a torn achilles he looks fresh and
ready to go and then aj brown and a
revitalized odell beckham jr boy is he
happy to be
all right we have four legendary picks
to show you last one standing squad ride
leader they get the jersey greg is gonna
boost the odds we're all gonna throw
some cash on it and have ourselves a
saturday and then a sunday so let's get
right into it right now the first one is
from michael cala who are you picking a
score this weekend
what took so long all right boss i'm
cooking up some locks bro
here's your pizza
be all better than this for you
aj brown anytime touchdown scorer trust
me on that one we got this
my local northeastern friends going with
aj brown he's your pizza all right first
matchup of the week is coming in from
amar nza taking on the pizza legend
let's see if it's enough to knock them
off
my man is in a real life tank greg that
is a first for the squad ride coming in
with cooper cup so we got a wide
receiver standoff in the first round
greg let him know what we need and i'm
going to ask you which are you riding
this is a tough opener we're starting
with
this is a tough one but what i need
everybody to do in the comments is let
me let my friend connor and let
everybody else in the comments know who
you are riding with are you taking aj
brown
are you
taking cooper cup connor this one's
tough this one is tough aj brown him and
uh ryan tenhail they've been they've
been clicking as of late they've been
clicking as of late plus 140 looks like
good money
but i i i question i just question their
chemistry i just questioned if they're
going to click today
because they're getting back derrick
henry and and
when he's coming back i just don't know
how they're going to jail i don't know
if they're going to run the ball
majority of the day i don't know if
they're going to play action i don't
know if they're gonna pass the ball it's
just a lot of questions so i'm gonna
stay away from the aj brown uh pick
and i feel safe i feel as safe as matt
stafford right now when he throws the
ball to cooper cup cooper cup sitting at
minus 135 connor you know what we can do
here
i like cooper cup man he's been doing it
all year i i like i like the rams in
this matchup
i'm taking cooper cup connor which way
are you riding
and i love to hear that because i'm
doing the same the playoffs are all
about trust right i don't care about the
odds yeah it's great that it's plus 140
guess what it doesn't mean anything if
it doesn't happen so i look at this i
think minus 135 for cup is actually
really nice especially when you take
into account where greg is going to take
those odds so the rams look good right
now i think they might surprise some
people this weekend and even if they
don't we know cooper cup is going to get
his so minus 135 and i shout out to the
tank legend right we have not seen that
one before it gives you a little boost
so we're going with cup
greg where are the comments going
let me hop into the handy dandy ipad for
those that don't know this is the handy
dandy ipad this is how you get your
hoodies this is how you will get jerseys
this is how you will get 250 dk dollars
and also this is how somebody will be
walking away with some airpod max is
all happening right here i got uh
i got obese 800 obese 800 says cooper
cup is a lock shout out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie um i got
mme9 says cup henry is going to get the
yards in td so he's rocking with cooper
cup shout out to you mme i'm gonna get
one more in here connor one more in here
uh the comments are jumping i got s
young 37 says cup will erupt i like that
i like what he did there so connor
i'm making the call
cooper cup is moving on to the next
round brother
and i like it you know we're riding with
that one a good call cooper cup moving
on to round two
it's not over yet in round two familiar
face ben merrick bringing it this week
let's see what ben's got cooking up
cooking up for us
[Music]
the rare teammate standoff match up on
the squad ride cooper cup
but his teammate across from him who's
been good since he's been with the rams
in odell beckham coming in at plus 160
ben merrick the toast legend going with
obg
all right greg both rams we like what
the rams are are looking like this week
against that buck secondary
is this enough to sway you do both of
them score where are we going here
connor
first and foremost first and foremost i
need everybody that's watching everybody
in the comments let us know if you're
rocking with obj
or if you're rocking with cooper cup in
this matchup right here these are
teammates as connor mentioned
connor i'm
man
i i strongly feel the rams are are
letting odell be great during the
playoffs i think that they're just
letting them go
i think that
odell can take this team to the next
level if he gets going i strongly feel
that way we know what cooper cup does
that is matt stafford's safety blanket
but if odell gets going this rams team
look out for them look out for this rams
team
so with that being said conor with that
being said
i'm not gonna lie bro i will sprinkle
some money on odell beckham jr i will
sprinkle some money on him to score in
this matchup plus 160 we saw what he did
last week
i would sprinkle some money and you know
what we can do here on the squad right
it's plus 160 now connor we're just
gonna take it up brother but talk to me
talk to the people which way are you
leaning are you going the safety route
or are you taking chances
man i like them both honestly and when
you look at what todd bowles is going to
try to do to game plan against these
rams you got to take away cooper cup and
that's going to leave the match-ups for
odell beckham who has shown lately
that he's up for the challenge so and
listen cooper cup is the reliable guy it
doesn't matter when teams try to erase
them it doesn't work so it doesn't mean
you're writing off cooper cup but when
you're just playing the odds game and
what this rams team has to do to pull
off an upset they got to feed other guys
they they need cam acres to be great
they need odell beckham to be great they
need those other skill guys to step up
if the bucks are going to dedicate so
much of the coverage up front and in the
back bracket cooper cup so
if people want to lean odell beckham
here i'm not going to kill him i have no
problem with that which way are they
leaning
let me find out connor let me jump into
the handy dandy ipad and find out i got
little saint 814 says pick me and the
tank with a cooper cup gift shout out to
you little saint a14 you are walking
away with the hoodie uh
i also have i also have uh c the man 14
says cooper with some fire emojis he's
rocking with cooper cup shout out to you
you are walking away with the hoodie uh
connor
br bedding is in the comments man shout
out to br bennett's squad ride for the
troops that's what they are saying
maxwell rexella was in the comments
talking about cooper cup therefore
we are riding
with cooper cup moving on to the next
round everybody that i mentioned
everybody that i mentioned you all are
walking away with hoodies
but connor
cooper cup is moving on to the next
round
cooper cup two for two he makes it three
for three the squad ride leader the tank
legend would be the squad rod leader and
it's gonna take a big time contender to
knock him off in round three so let's
take a look from big mike boy and see if
he's got the contender that can get the
job done
hey there greg and connor what i have
unlocked in the safe is the anytime tv
lock for this playoff weekend let's go
ahead and check it out
contender it is devonte adams those odds
are tied minus 135 it tells you what
vegas thinks about both of these guys
and their chances of getting in the end
zone
you know what greg
this is going to be enough for me right
here i will get off the cooper cup train
for the devonte adams train i am an
absolute last second trader in this spot
i love the pick devonte adams if we can
get that one boosted let's take it home
are you with me i know it's against your
niners but you're also a smart man a
balanced man when it comes to gambling
do you like devonte adams to score this
week
i would like to think that i'm a smart
man when it comes to gambling the
audience might think something different
but connor
i was at that week three matchup
49ers taking on the packers it was a
close game came down to the last seconds
in fact uh crosby kicked the field goal
and won the game
but there was one thing that was
constant throughout that game
and that was devonte adams torching the
49ers cornerbacks
it was it was like
every play you saw aaron rodgers
literally staring down my guy devonte
adams and still completing the ball to
him
i think that continues today
um i can see my guy devonte adams
scoring a touchdown today
so connor
you might have got me bro you might have
got me to sway on the other side i
honestly i like both of these picks i'll
sprinkle money on both of these picks
but uh i'ma go to the comments right now
because i want to see what they are
talking about so we can choose who we
are riding together as a family uh i
like like i said i like both pics but
i'm in the handy danny ipad right now
looking for takes and i see i see
wattages wattage it says greg hates it
but you gotta go adam's brother i do not
hate it
i do not hate it i am a realist i know
what the packers are gonna try to do
today against my 49ers but uh why did
this you are walking away with the
hoodie also
also my boy ritter was in the comments
mike ritter br bedding's finest he
mentioned that tay was from the bay
devonta adams is from the bay
or close to it so shout out to you
ritter uh i i i got one more one more in
me
one more in me i got d boy 22 d boy 22
says adams is going to get two
touchdowns let's go connor i think the
people are spoken i mean the comments is
all devonte adams cooper cup is nowhere
to be mentioned
so therefore
we
everybody are riding devonta adams two
score touchdown to score a touchdown
today uh let's pull up let's pull up the
odds let's put the odds so i can show
you guys what we are going to do today
on the squad rise you guys see that it's
-135
let's see the magic guys in the control
room there it is plus 100 now
go get it go get it uh
connor
[Music]
we we did it bro we changed it from
minus 135 to plus 100 let me give out
uh jersey and let me give out 250 dk
dollars right now i'm back into the
comments connor i am back into the
comments rob dog 22 rob dog 22 says
devonta the man adam's two touchdowns
today baby shout out to you
uh robdog22
you are walking away with
250 dk dollars for your take i love your
gift too uh so shouts out to you and i'm
also giving away a jersey i got one more
jersey lots of no it's off it's actually
loft bird loft burn devonta adams is on
fire go pack go shout out to you love
burn you are walking away with the
jersey connor let's get let's get to
segment two bro let's go let's go
hey man we had a lot of fun with the
touchdown scorers devonte adams boosted
up the plus 100 you know what to do when
the show is over don't waste any time
and keep the comments jumping so we got
a lot to give away speaking of that greg
we got a lot of these match-ups to go
through this is just a phenomenal slate
of games and we're gonna give all of our
favorite major market bets of the week
last week we were talking money lines
and now we're not afraid to get in on
that action again but instead this week
we're going to go best bets from each
match-up but first i need you to do
something you got to get on draftkings
right you've got to get on draftkings
because the first time customers can
place a money line bet of five dollars
or more during the post season and if
your bet wins you'll receive
280 dollars in free bets in addition to
your cash winnings greg i think you like
the sound of that right
yes sir connor i love the sound of that
and connor and i are gonna are going
game by game and giving
you our favorite major market picks get
in the comments and tell us what you
think
about our picks i'm giving away hoodies
i'm giving away jerseys and i'm also
giving away another connor
another 250 dk dollars bro i love giving
away those 250 dk dollar pro that is a
parlay that's a parlay bro you put the
250 down on the parlay you're bubbling
that's a big time parlay and speaking of
those parlays here we might take some of
these best bet picks put them together
for one at the end of this so stick
around first up we got the bengals going
to nashville tennessee because the
titans are the number one seed in the
afc maybe the most hated on number one
seed of all time so the bengals three
and a half points separate these teams
right now you see the point total set at
a very average 47 and a half man greg
i'm looking at this game i think it's
one of the harder ones to predict i like
the bengal spread a lot but my best bet
i'm going to take that point total up
just a little bit to 51 and a half and
go under i know everybody's on joe
burrow slicing and dicing this titan
secondary everybody's jacked up that
derek henry is back but i look at this
one and that to me just means more run
game i think they are going to lean on
joe mixon for the bengals i think that
clock will continue to tick it's a lot
of points so i like changing the point
total and going under where are you
going with the first game of divisional
weekend
i see i see what you're doing connor i'm
right here with you i see what you're
doing you know taking it up and then
going under i see what you're doing but
connor i'm going to pick a side here i'm
not going to go over under i'm going to
pick a side and i'm going money line no
spread money line i'm going with the
bengals man it's been a hot pick people
been talking about it all my life people
been dm to me about it
the bengals against the titans you say
the one of the most hated or on one
seeds ever probably uh so
i'm i'm hating on them nah nah no haters
no hate no way but i'm rocking with the
bengals connor i'm a rock with the
bengals and i'm a rock with that money
line that that that plus 155 is just
looking too
tempting for me
all right greg where are the comments
going right now i feel like so much of
the public does like the bengals is
laughing at the titans we're gonna see
how that shakes out and obviously the
bengals are a hot team right now how the
comments feeling about this matchup
connor i got richie 21 in the comments
saying titans henry is coming to eat
today they think henry is going to be
eating um
lothburn is back he says it's a great
day to bet to bet football shout out to
you uh be our best is in the comments be
our petting is in the comments plus
money greg uh
yeah i'm a i'm a pickle i'm a pickle
senior bengals got it
everybody that i mentioned even br
betting you were walking away with the
hoodie uh connor let's get to this next
match up
let's get to it let's do it because it's
your niners going to the tundra in
lambeau field the most exciting matchup
of our saturday right here two old
school franchises five points separates
them another average point total at 47.
keep in mind how cold it is there
and you know your niners getting some
plus money there greg but i'm looking at
this game and i will pick assad i'm not
going to be bold enough to pick the
packers to win by almost a touchdown but
i will say money line and that's because
i have to my only super bowl futures
ticket left is the packers i have no
choice i can't jump ship now i apologize
greg there's no disrespect
where are you going though do you
believe in your niners to get the job
done on the road
connor i'll say this week three i was
there in santa clara watching the
packers take on the 49ers the packers
controlled the game for most of the game
i'm not gonna lie they controlled the
game but guess what jimmy g and the boys
came battling back at the end
but
aaron rodgers had too much time left
went down the field kicked the field
goal it was a close game i'm saying all
this because it was a close game i don't
know where the odd maker see almost a
touchdown you know i don't see i don't i
i don't know what what they're thinking
uh but they see this as they see this as
the packers winning by almost a
touchdown i do not i think this is going
to be a close game therefore i'm rocking
with the 49ers
spread i'm walking with the 49er spread
connor i also want to mention this i
mentioned this last week and i'll
mention it again
in the nfl
it is extremely hard to beat a team
twice
and i'll just leave it at that
take the niners plus the points tonight
man is it ever it absolutely is it's a
good point greg this is going to be
uh an exciting game i don't think it'll
be a blowout and they're trying to tell
you that vegas thinks there's a chance
it will so we're gonna have our eyes on
that one i think which way the comments
leaning right now because the packers
have been
these super bowl favorite on every
futures board that's still out there
right now you can still get in on the
action and we'll look at that later but
the niners huge fan base hot team kyle
shanahan has been to the super bowl
before and this isn't just with the
niners he did it with the falcons as
well so there's a big reason to believe
in kyle which way are the comments
leaning in this game
you
uh the comments is jumping connor a bang
bang niner gang is in the comments you
guys see the gif right there
city
3184 got the george kittle gift going
shout out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie i also got george ny 22 gc
you guys see it right there he says debo
stealing green bay's bike today rocking
with the niners i got one more connor
one more and we're gonna go right here
to peter
raider909 he's confused because he's a
raider fan no i'm just kidding but
raider 909 green bay by 10 points this
time around and he is stretching
i guess all the niner fans up uh shout
out to you raider909
you are walking away with a hoodie
all right let's get sunday matchups
yes sir
thanks to sunday we got the rams going
to tampa the reigning super bowl champs
with the bucks and man rams looked
pretty good last week so this is going
to be a lot of people never pick against
tom brady but this one's tight you're
seeing the plus two and a half of the
rams plus money there once again another
point total right around 47 for the
third time in a row
all right greg for this one i'm keeping
that parlay ticket in mind i like the
ram spread and i like it to four and a
half i want the field goal here greg so
i'm gonna buy some extra points it's not
gonna change the odds that much because
two and a half is plus money so i'll get
it to four and a half here i think they
at least hang around with the bucks
it might even surprise them are you with
me on this one
connor
i am with you on this one but brother
but
i'm not
i'm not buying no points connor i'm not
gonna buy any points
the plus two and a half you look at it
brother it's plus money it's plus money
i honestly i think the rams win this
game so i'm just gonna play it safe plus
two and a half it's plus money even
money give it to me i'm gonna take that
and i'm rocking with the the rams to
cover the spread against tom brady and
those uh
those injured tampa bay buccaneers
all right so we're on the rams
i would imagine the public is usually on
the bucks and there are a lot of rams
doubters
where are our comments right now are
they buying the rams upset are they
rolling with over libel literally old
reliable tom brady
he said literally old reliable i like
that connor uh i got s young 37 says all
shucks it's the bucks
i don't really know what he means by
that but you are walking away with the
hoodie for your take uh the raider fan
uh raider fan 4209 has the ram
you see that you guys see the gif right
there i don't have to explain it you
guys see it on your screen uh therefore
raider fan 4 4209 there is his username
right there as you guys can see uh hold
on let me get it in you guys frame there
it is right there raider fan 4209 you
are also walking away with
a hoodie i got one more in me connor one
more in me oh let's talk to master jedi
right here
the o-line is heard for tampa bay
defensive line for la is one of the best
use the force take the rams and the
points brother we are taking the rams
and the points so uh shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned
you all are walking away with hoodies
connor
we got one more game left right
one more game and it is projected as the
tightest match of them all with the
bills going to kansas city and when you
look at that one it is only a point and
a half difference right now
now we've gone 47 47 47 for the point
totals we are going to jack that up by a
touchdown all the way up to 54. so they
are expecting shootout city with josh
allen and patrick mahomes i mean
undisputed the top two quarterbacks in
the afc right now in this game this is
going to be a thriller they're saving it
for sunday evening building that
excitement and greg for me it's about
the points in this one keeping the
parlay in mind i'm going to go down to
about 50 and a half points here and say
that smash is over i like allen to throw
on the chiefs but i know andy reid and
patrick mahomes will punch back so i
like the points to get a little crazy in
this one what are you thinking for
bill's chiefs
i'm right there with you connor i'm
literally right there with you i'm going
over here i think this was gonna be a
shootout we got two really good offenses
and then we have a uh
sort of ailing defense with the chiefs
so uh i see a lot of offense i see a lot
of fireworks and i see a lot of points
being scored uh i'm rocking with the
over here brother i am
rocking with the over and i can't wait
to watch this one tomorrow
all right tightest matchup of the
weekend what are the people thinking for
this one they rolling with josh allen
are they on the hype train for josh
allen to reign supreme are they sticking
with patrick mahomes
i got steve city steve oh actually city
31
84 you see the stefan diggs gift right
there but hold on he also dropped
this gift right here of the buffalo
right there so shout out to you that's
wicked 31.84 you're walking away with a
hoodie up let's also talk to c big b you
guys see him right there bill's not
stopping in kansas city l.a bound for
sure shout out to uc big b you're
walking away with hoodie one more one
more you guys see logan down there logan
l three i ggz
says cheese
so shout out to you logan uh you are
also rocking away with any everybody
that i mentioned you all are walking
away with the vr betting
hoodie
all right let's make things interesting
you've heard all our picks
let's mash them all together into one
big parlay over here from every big time
game
this week and greg let him know what we
need the people to do right now to get
in on the action of all these giveaways
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell us if you're a riding with me
or my man connor
if you guys are riding with either of us
and i'm giving away hoodies i'm giving
away jerseys and i'm also
that 250 parlay dk dollars
i'm giving away that as well connor
yeah it's a pretty sweet deal all right
let's take a look at these parlays right
now to show the people a little reminder
to the people what we're working with
here all right here's mine first only
coming in at plus 433 playing it i guess
as safe as you could say for plus 433
we're looking under bought up for
bengals titans packers to win outright
rams the cover four and a half line and
then the shootout of the weekend bill's
chiefs it's got to get over 50. let's
take a look at greg's right now because
i know he came in bold on this one bold
and ready to go man
greg i like what you got cooking up here
remind the people what you got
yes nerd connor you already know we rock
it with the bang bang niner gang we rock
it with the spray with the niners and we
got bengals money line here connor been
hearing this one a lot like i mentioned
people in my dms people on my winners
only show been talking about the bengals
and i am writing so i'm taking money
line not the points we're taking money
line with the bengals
rams
plus two and a half this is plus money
connor the ram spread is plus money i'm
taking that as well
also i think that there's gonna be a
shoot out
in that kansas city buffalo bills game i
think this is good it's just i just
think a lot of points are going to be
scored in that one so uh yeah you round
all that up it's plus 17 58.
it's getting rich
i think this qualifies as your boldest
bet as well greg i think that's pretty
fair to say now i know you got
an nfl jersey
the 250 dk dollars
what are the people jumping off right
now what are they what are they on what
are they buying what are they selling
right now let them know i got garrett
beam in the comments garrett beam says
don't sleep over total and josh allen
first td score there it is right there i
love the take i love the take therefore
garrett
congratulations you are walking away
with 250 dk dollars and i hope i hope i
hope you go parlay that i hope you do so
shout out to you garrett uh also i'm
also giving away a jersey right uh
connor
oh yeah you got one more jersey and you
got plenty more after this but for this
one jersey
here we go we got htwo
he says riding with greg no scared money
on the ramps
even riding with the bengals and niners
all
even i'm sorry i'm sorry guys i
graduated college and i promised that
let me let me let me take another stab
at this riding with greg no scared money
on the ramps even riding with the
bengals and niners riding all the way i
think greg hits lock
there it is connor that's what my guy
htwo said in hcwo you are walking away
with the jersey your choice
all right shout out to the commenters
and don't forget get on draftkings take
advantage of that five dollars to win
280 deal that i read at the top of the
show when you lock your money line bets
this weekend pretty sweet all right
for the regulars for the loyal viewers
you know what time it is it's time for a
little prop lock or drop it and in honor
of divisional weekend our friends over
at draftkings are offering a same game
parlay special so we're gonna get in on
that parlay fun as well greg let him
know what we got going on
connor
everybody at home
place a minimum of ten dollar bet on any
divisional round game today and tomorrow
and receive
a free
bet
that's pretty good to me all right greg
we love a good parlay around here so i
think it's time as we tease the top
let's make things a little bit
interesting with the player props this
weekend
blend them all into a same game parlay
what do we got first up here
what first the first and foremost connor
first and foremost i need everybody
that's watching
to get in the comments and tell us
whether
to lock
or drop
these props uh let's get to the first
one connor let's get to the first one
aaron rodgers over or under
aaron rodgers over or under
254 and a half yards uh
connor are you locking this one in or
are you dropping this one
yeah i'm locking me over here for aaron
rodgers i think he comes out firing i
think he comes out ready to go against
that nine or secondary i think you're
gonna see a big day not surprisingly for
devonte adams but most importantly a big
day through the year so this isn't a
scary number there's no reason to fear
it i know they're going to want to run
the ball they got a lot of their top
defenders back they'll play good defense
but aaron is aaron he's going to come
out ripping that thing greg are you i
know this is a tough one but are you
rolling with me here are we going to
keep this one moving
uh
i mean
i mentioned
i'll talk about this i mentioned that
i've saw with my own eyes what aaron
rodgers did to that 49er secondary
connor
and i think that he possibly has a
chance at doing it again don't mean he's
going to win the game but i think that
he can get his today by just simply
throwing the ball to devonta adams so
i'm going to rock with the over
yeah and if it's a close game
he's just going to be throwing the ball
more to try to get it uh
try to get that win so across from him
is your boy jimmy g looking at jimmy g's
over under this week
not that different
244.5 only 10 yards less than rodgers
and for people at home
thinking it's absolutely crazy jimmy's
thrown for over 300 in two of his last
three games so jimmy can rack up the art
totals it helps when you have debo
samuel out there to chuck it too and
just let him run around the field but
those count the box score they count for
the bets
i'm still afraid of this one for jimmy g
because he's banged up it's the packers
they got a lot of big dogs back on their
defense i'm gonna go under here greg
where are you going
i'm right there with you connor uh i'm
an iron fan everybody here knows
but i'm
it's hard for me to put my money on
jimmy g connor i'll be honest it's hard
for me to trust and put my money on
jimmy g
but with that being said uh i'm i'm
rocking with the under here i think the
niners
are gonna try to control the ball
they're gonna try to control the time of
possession they're gonna try to run the
ball with eli mitchell i think they're
gonna try to keep the ball
out of aaron rodgers hands or they're
gonna they're trying to connor and with
all that being said i think that
my man jimmy g will not go over his uh
his passing yards total so i'm gonna
rock with the under all right looking at
the receivers and the receiving yards
total we're gonna start with the star of
the show so far and that's devonte adams
only at 89 and a half so just got to get
to that 90 marker and usually i call
these sucker bets or traps because they
are set high and it's with a star
but he's too good he is too good devonta
adams and this is aaron rodgers guy the
niner secondary has their question marks
i'm gonna go the over here i think
devonte can easily be in for that
hundred yard kind of day greg
yeah uh everybody stop what you're doing
go on your local betting site
and go bet this bet right now go bet
this bet right now because i can see my
guy devonte adams going over this easily
i seen it with my own eyes i'm telling
you guys i've seen it with my own eyes
week three against the 49ers the
chemistry between aaron rodgers and
devonte adams was like no other it was
like no other it didn't matter what the
niners did they just could not stop
devonte adams and that might happen
today i hope it doesn't but it might
happen today but i'm putting my money on
this connor i'll put my money on the
over and i'll i feel pretty confident
about it
a well-balanced fan all right the last
prop check here for the parlay ticket
got to bring it back to the niners we're
going with george kittle
set at 59 and a half he has not come
close to this the last couple of games
he's not been
a focal point of the passing attack he
has been dominating as a blocker that's
how good kittle is he could do just
about everything at the position
now that could mean that he's due greg
and he goes for 80 90. but i'm gonna go
with what we've seen for a while i think
the niners like the blocking aspect of
kittle establish that run game i could
see him popping off for 40 45 maybe even
50. his number's too high for me greg
under
yeah i'm i'm right there with you connor
i am right there with you uh we don't
know which george kettle are we getting
today are we getting
the run block george kittle
are we getting the
receiving george kittle the the all-pro
tight end receiving george like
he's an all-pro he's an all-pro even
blocking he's in all pro but
we just don't know which george kettle
are we getting and putting my money on
it i'm just kind of skeptical about that
uh i mentioned what the 49ers
should do in this matchup knights give
the ball to eli mitchell find bebo a
couple of times control the time of
possession um so i'm gonna rock with the
under here as well as as well as with
you connor i'm gonna rock with the under
and my guy george kittle going over that
receiving total
all right so greg and i saw eye to eye
on all four props which means we have a
pretty juicy parlay ticket we're ready
to show you and while we get to that
greg you have once again as the segment
closes in nfl jersey
hoodies
and
you know the deal 250 dk dollars so get
on in there
give it all away
here it is this is where it happens
right here connor i got bad sports takes
bad sports says kittle is going
little he's going under you guys see it
right there yep you guys see it uh
shout out to you brother you are walking
away with a jersey for that bad sports
take shout out to you you're walking
away with a jersey
oh you guys just saw the comments jump
oh i like this one i like this one you
guys see the grandma's right there see
the unt's right there that's that's
spicy angel
under he is blocking they're talking
about george kittle saying that he's
gonna be blocking so shout out to you
spicy angel you
my friend are walking away with 250
dk dollars please parlay that
and my guys spicy angel let's take a
look at something you can use those dk
dollars on here is greg and i's prop
parlay ticket for packers
49ers you already know the deal by now
we're going over aaron rodgers passing
yards under jimmy g's passing yards over
devonte adams receiving yards
under george kittle
receiving yards shout out to draftkings
for hooking us up this weekend make sure
to get your same game parlays locked
before the game starts alright moving on
community comments contest time we
watched the show last week we asked you
as part of the squad ride to help which
quarterback was throwing for the most
passing yards this week we got back to
our route and wanted an anytime
touchdown score for those of you that
missed it
but
you know the deal by now if you rode
with us last week you cashed big we're
gonna ask for your help again before we
get to some of your favorite responses
let's take a look at the odds for this
week's passers so far
we got tom brady at the top plus 380
mahomes who was our big time winner and
boosted up to plus 750 last week sitting
at plus 425 against the bills stafford
borough i'm a little surprised by josh
allen at plus 500 i might have some work
to do when we shut down today's show
then of course you've got rogers and the
big time dogs
tannehill jimmy g they're back there to
hand the ball off so we picked two of
our favorite comments and want to know
what you think greg i know you've got
your hands on these what are they
looking like and what do we need right
now
i need everybody to get in the comments
and tell me which of these is the better
take i'm giving a hoodie to whoever
you guys choose let's take a look at the
first comment from ak-47
big blue
says titan's secondary has been iffy at
times and right now
bengals are so hot gotta go with joe
burrow p.s
the bengals will win connor
you know how i feel about this one we
already gave out our parlays and the
bengals money line was on my ticket talk
to me talk to me nice connor do you see
this happening today
well shout out to asher just for the ps
the bengals will win way to put it on
the line i like this comment i like the
bengals
i don't know if joe burrow is gonna take
home this title but i think it's a
really good argument he's got a good one
he's got jamar chase he's got t higgins
that tennessee secondary like he said
they don't scare you too much i mean
they really don't so
this is a big time contender what else
we got here from the comments greg
connor
the next one let's see the next comment
is from big mike 13. i think big mike is
in the comments right now big mike says
i'm seeing josh allen ready to show he
belongs with the elite quarterbacks and
after last year with pigs watching the
celebration connor
they are ready to eat
i know you're from new york connor i
know you are from new york
are you feeling this one bro are you
think the bills are really ready to eat
big mike is all over it and this is
coming from a new york jets fan but that
just means that i know how real the
bills are how real josh allen is
this is spot on and this is both he's
plus 500 so this isn't a chalky pick
he's right ready to show he belongs he
is an elite quarterback right now but a
win against the chiefs at kansas city
would establish it as a lock no one can
argue against that and i like that
callback about stefan diggs they've been
thinking about this for a long time
they're gonna be ready to go greg i like
this one a lot
yes sir
you like this one and guess what i like
doing connor i like going to the handy
dandy ipad because this is where i give
people hoodies this is where i give
people jerseys this is where i give
people 250 to go put in the parlay i
mean it gets no better than the handy
dandy ipad and right now i'm in the
handy dandy ipad and big mike guess what
big mike is in the car not watching that
celebrating again uh
he's rocking with josh hey big mike you
are walking away with a hoodie you're
walking around with a hoodie big mike uh
he's in the comments right now connor
so i'm just gonna call it i'm gonna call
it right here big mike
you're in the comments right now
so therefore brother
you are a big fan of the show you were
you were riding with us you you you sent
this your comment before the show you're
in the comments right now and therefore
i am sending you
two hoodies
uh no actually i'm sending you a hoodie
and i'm gonna sing you some dk dollars
bro so you're walking away with the dk
dollars and walking away with a hood
[Music]
well big mike's cleaning up here greg
and we appreciate it actually i'm a big
fan of the show take it away
actually hold on hold on i just got word
i just got word that my guy big mike
you're actually walking away with some
airpods bro so you're walking away with
those airpods maxes that i wish that i
had because i don't even have airpod
maxes
oh man congrats to big mike we
appreciate you supporting vr betting as
greg said is sending you a pair of air
pods and you got the hoodie but we still
got more hoodies jerseys dk dollars
and airpods max to give away they help
people like me that don't stay in the
ears they're going to clip over the ears
so keep it up in the comments before we
move on to our boldest bets we got
something a little special in store for
you guys as you know one of our favorite
props to ride all year we did it for
monday night football every single week
has been the no score first drive but
it's the playoffs so our friends at
draftkings are spicing things up a bit
for us
this week greg let him know what they
got planned
that's right connor the question is this
weekend
will the opening offense score in the
first drive of the bills chief game
tomorrow
actually tomorrow uh draftkings is
boosting the odds from plus 110 to plus
150 connor
i'm excited about this one i'm not even
gonna lie i'm excited about this one
because i said i i said
this one's gonna be a shootout connor
you also said this was gonna be a
shootout so i'm rocking with yes i think
that they're going to go out and start
shooting
start the shootout get the shootout
going from the beginning of the game so
i'm rocking with the yes which way are
you leaning connor
i'm with you all the way i would i love
this boost right the plus 110 is nice as
it is plus 150. i think the teams know
coming into this game especially if the
bills get the ball on the road and they
they start out with the ball you have to
score you have to dictate the pace of
this game you can't be playing from
behind
neither team can play from behind i know
they got the quarterbacks to do it but
listen they're going to be very
desperate greg i think they're going to
be
taking risks i think they'll go for it
on fourth down especially on the other
side of the 50. i love this boost i'm
going with points as well are the people
going with opening points as well
handy dandy ipad there it is oh connor
handy danny ipad is out i got ben
ben s-o-n-k 6-1-9 you guys see it right
there he says yes yes yes also under him
c big b c big b yes scoring won't stop
crazy all day shout out to youtube you
are walking away with
hoodies
you guys are welcome
cbb c big b i'm sorry c big b you're
walking away with a jersey why not whoa
why not greg greg swished it up on him
he's like yeah you got a hoodie nah you
got a jersey all right that's a big
winner and greg and i are hoping to be
big winners because it is boldest bets
time this is what we wait for win or
lose don't care keep firing away hold
this bets time
and greg i know you got
hoodies jerseys still more dk dollars
left
tell the people if they're new to this
by now they've been hanging with us for
an hour what they gotta do to get in on
the action during our boldest bets
hey what i need y'all to do we gonna
keep it short sweet and concise what i
need y'all to do is just let us know if
you're rocking with me or if you rock
with my boy connor over there but connor
let's get to it bro let's let's not
let's not stall any more time let's get
straight to what you're taking bro
all right greg i got a little out of
control this week i saw the draftkings
picking anytime touchdown score from
every game parlay get it boosted 25
here it is bengals titans jamar chase
plus money okay devonte adams who was
our squad ride leader i didn't even know
that yet davonte adams cooper cub the
runner up for squad ride leader
and then devin singletary he goes by the
name of motor and he's gonna motor his
way into the end zone on the chief's
home turf plus
15.75
that is right you just sprinkle a little
bit of money on this get crazy or the
first two hit today if you're scared
don't be scared you cash out tomorrow
morning go by yourself and your lady or
whoever it may be a nice breakfast greg
what are you going with for boldest bets
this week hey that was really bold
connor that that was extremely bold
online between bold and stupid my friend
[Laughter]
i would be a little bold
no actually i'm gonna be big bo right
here i've been talking about the bengals
i've been talking about them all show
and it's not gonna stop connor nothing's
gonna change i'm rocking with the
bengals check this one out connor
alternate spread alternate spread minus
four i see the bengals getting this win
and it's not by a field goal connor it's
by more than that so give me the big leg
liken the underdog to
win big greg win big i love
yes it yes sir i think the bengals go
turn up today conor i think they go turn
up offense is gonna uh show out a little
bit
and uh the titans we just don't know
which which version are we getting are
we gonna get the derrick henry running
the ball 20 times are we gonna get
you know my guy tannehill trying to
trying to connect with aj brown trying
to connect with julio i i i just don't
know so many questions about that titans
team i'm rocking with the banks
all right before we move on
got some big time giveaways we want to
know
from the people and greg's going to
check in
are you riding with me are you riding
with greg are you riding with your own
boldest bets don't be shy get in there
and and share what you got greg
what do they got for us right now
connor i think vegas is calling me right
now i think they're trying to uh give me
a lock but
but uh
uh i'm going to the comments i'm going
to the comments and i'm going to give
away some some some some hoodies and
some dk dollars i got
let me see i got
ny22gc says boat and beautiful bet
connor taking this one greg
i don't know who they're riding with
hunter but um
shout out to you you're walking away
with hoodie also i got city 3184 says
why not both i love that energy i love
that energy i'm sending 250 dk dollars
to you
so shout out to you thank you guys thank
you guys for uh for commenting shout out
to everybody that i mentioned if you if
i met you you're walking with hoodie or
250 dk dollars
all right good vibes in the comments
during boldest bets and we're going to
keep them rolling because it's time for
a little grand prize giveaway you heard
me mention it not that long ago we got
the airpods max giveaway on tap and
we're looking for something simple
but so complex best bets to win the
super bowl that is right best bets to
win the super bowl let's take a look at
those super bowl odds as it stands right
now the green bay packers at the top
chiefs bills then the reigning champs
getting a little disrespect there plus
550 for the bucks rams and titans is
where the big underdogs come in and then
set your niners and the bengals who you
also like getting zero love really
almost disrespect at this point all the
way at the bottom greg let them know
what they got to do if they want to get
in on the action for these airpods
hey if you guys want to get in on the
action for these airpods i need you guys
to get in the comments and tell me your
locks to win the championship we're
gonna spin the wheel and if your comment
matches the team chosen by the wheel you
could win a pair of airpod
maxes
it's pretty sweet pretty sweet deal all
right that is i'm gonna drop my bet my
bet here i said it earlier i still have
a packers ticket i know they're the
favorite on that board whatever chunky
pick i like the packers you cannot
predict the wheel let me say that the
wheel is not going to take the favorite
or by default greg i think you still
have a futures ticket left that is not a
favorite right now what do you got right
now
connor everybody knows i'm a 49er fan
and um brother
i have one i have a 49er futures ticket
uh
i have a future 49ers to win the nfc i
have a future ticket for the 49ers to
win the nfc and i also have a future
ticket for the 49ers to win the super
bowl so uh hopefully i'm cashing brother
hopefully i'm cashing
and hopefully i'm getting rich
in in february
that's right all right greg it's time to
spin the wheel if your pick matches the
wheel you can win a pair of air pods max
that'll depend on how the comments go
let's spin it let's get this thing going
let's get this thing rolling i think
it's going to go for a little bit while
here so get excited get in the comments
get going get fired up make your pick
let's see where we land
let's see where it goes let's see where
it goes it's turning it's turning and it
is
passing the 49ers okay
titans
tie-ins the wheel has spoken and they
are going with the number one seed that
is the titans although they are not
number one on the odds board right now
who's taking home those airpods max day
who had the titans who from nashville is
fired up right now greg do we have a
winner is there anyone in there
connor i ain't even gonna lie man i
what the titans
oh wait wait wait i got one
king of sports 21 one out of the
many
titans going to win it all they got all
the offense with king henry gotta go
with these high odds and bravo is going
to win coach of the year this is the
year for the titans to win it all
there it is connor there it is uh
there's those air pop matches that
they're they're gone they're gone to my
guy king of sports shout out to you e
you're walking away with the airpod
maxes
what a take what a pick and if you hear
the sirens going off that means it's
time to go i gotta go so we're done here
you know the deal though we'll be back
congrats to the winners king of sports
the big winner i didn't even think we'd
have someone i thought you or i would
have to play rock paper for uh those
airpods greg that would have been fun
all right get in on the action you know
the deal you saw the custom boost you
saw the props
get in on the parlay that devonte adams
plus 100 you'd be a fool right now not
to throw a little bit on that action
draftkings five dollars to win 280. it's
a great deal for new users getting on
the money line action
for yes the score on the first drive
bill's chief's boosted the plus 150 from
plus one
nuts nuts
this is
i don't want to say free greg
but this is fun money fun odds being
spread around and you know the same game
parlay promo right now please send us
your reaction videos this weekend as the
games go on especially if you're rooting
for one of these teams if you're rooting
for somebody that you bet on send the
reaction videos maybe we'll throw it in
the show
and we want to see the real time takes
on social in the br sports betting
community stream
join us next sunday
sunday at 11 a.m you're getting used to
these saturday afternoons we've been
chilling gives greg and i a little time
to get some coffee some breakfast maybe
shake a hangover whatever it may be
sunday we're back next morning we'll be
good to go thank you so much everyone
i'm connor rogers greg ivory we'll catch
you next week
[Music]